600 trillion uh yeah trillion well when
you hear numbers like that it's just
like what it you know it's like what is
that even me the only the only time that
anyone has ever used those numbers
outside of the national debt is in like
physics when you're talking about the
numbers of like particles in the
universe you know it's like it it takes
that kind of like that something that
massive otherwise these numbers are
completely and totally impractical the
human can't even comprehend it and it's
the rate of change that's also where it
becomes highly impa holy you guys ready
for this yeah the US federal debt to GDP
ratio was
124.401
remember remember 1980 I wasn't alive we
all know about the Jimmy Carter era and
John lennin John Lennon died in December
of 1980 my mother say wasn't 1980 the
the uh 34.7